I can feel people distancing themselves
from me for my
stance professionally and
personally and
um so if you don't know who this girl is
who looks like a hot mess on camera she
if you arili with AB preach Flor this
predates are popularity on YouTube this
was back in like I'm going to say
2017 17 yeah around that time we we had
we we we we went back and forth with her
because she was saying a bunch of goofy
stuff what was she saying low key Noble
that's from her no before that she was
it's when it's when she it's this is the
sequel to this it's when she tried to
enter a party that she was not invited
to and then she still tried to force
herself in and they scored her ass out
and we was like yo what are you saying
and then after that she just back story
back story she is an actress on uh I
believe it's not blackish I think it's
is it it's Nota R show insecure insecure
okay my bad I don't watch these shows
enough so she goes to one of the parties
for the show and the publicist for Isa
re says Nah Amanda you can't come in
Amanda gets on Instagram it turns to
this big thing she turned into a racial
thing for the record I am being denied
entrance to the black people's Emmy
party and it's a white woman telling me
I can't go in just I just want to put
this on record that I'm literally being
told you cannot get entered entrance
into a party that Jesse Williams invited
you to that is the only black event for
the end weend because a white woman is
telling me I can't get
her yeah yeah because she said the white
woman Kiara I remember that part too she
started losing it and people were very
divided people felt some type of way but
what we were saying is like sometimes
it's not everybody else sometimes you're
just difficult and people don't want you
around sometimes you're hard to deal
with sometimes it's not your skin it's
what's underneath you understand now you
might want to say it's your skin but
it's actually what's underneath where'd
you get that what where'd you get that
from that's saying I I know I don't I I
came up with that's a bar okay there you
go you didn't press hard on it enough
Hey listen listen sometime it's not your
skin it's what's underneath you're just
going to breathe that [__] we going bre
my God no full of nuggets I understand
so just drop she makes a big stinker and
we're like n you the diffult why you
acting like it's everybody else and then
she loses it right and everyone's
divided I don't want this to be an easy
interview I ready to address whatever
first of all are you still on insecure
what kind of dumbass question is that I
remember that I I remember that yeah
let's go back in the past because you
know what if you want to predict the
future sometimes you just got to look at
history just asking that is a dumb
question Dum question asking next
question who was the person that did not
like no we're not doing that but I'm
ready to address whatever whatever what
kind of dumbass question is that no
we're not doing that I here to address
everything I want to address not do that
my my girl you I think I've gotten in my
own way by being more honest than I
needed to be in certain situations this
is not conceit or Cockiness this is
somebody who has really sat here and
looked at this I think some people don't
like me because I'm very light-skinned
you know what this is
like this is like when you ask somebody
like uh yeah what's your biggest faults
it's like instead of giving you a fault
give themselves a compliment oh yeah
what's the biggest I'm too strong I'm
too honest I'm too honest it's like I'm
too wealthy you know like it's just some
about I have too much money so it makes
people afraid to be around
me that's what it feels like that's not
a fault that's not that's not a fault
wait here listen very light-skinned I
think some people don't like me because
I'm a woman with a very strong point of
view and an opinion I think some people
don't like me because I may reflect
something that they desire that's a
reason why some people might not like
you but why does nobody like
you
sorry sorry I'm sorry I think some
people don't like me for the reasons
that they don't like themselves and I
know that there are reasons you don't
like me that were handed down to you in
some situations by patriarchy I mean by
racism I mean by classism Etc you know
you don't like me because I can talk
proper or something you know like if
that's a source of ey are for you like
I'm I'm like mad that somebody put it in
you I think if we look at like the 100%
of that there's probably about 5% of
those situations where like yeah I owe
you an apology yeah you know you know
what yeah you know what fine yeah I owe
you money
here that is good that is good I got to
give that I forgot about I got to give
you that one I forgot about that he hey
hey [__] hey hey hey bro I'm not going
to I'm not going to front you that [__]
was cold that [__] was cold hey
yo hey preach you was on one for that
video oh I forgot about that sh okay oh
my God hey y yo [__] you carry change
on you at all times even though this
jacket ain't got no pockets for let's
keep going that was F I've been bullied
for being smart I don't know how being
unabashedly smart has become such a
villainous thing literally people think
that me being a critical thinker is me
being extra me being too much but there
were a lot of people who used to say
things like that about you know stokeley
carmichel about huip PE about Martin
Luther King like oh they stirring up
trouble
[Laughter]
wow you got to laugh at some of this now
now you're watching it back it's just
like oh wow I am [__] scer and mlly
I'm a crusader like I'm the Green Beret
but I have become the patrion saint for
difficult women in terms of like am I a
terrible person that's absolutely
ridiculous and absurd you I know people
will watch this and it like okay Amanda
said you know these are the reasons but
what do you think you did to that young
lady for her to feel that way towards
you I have no idea really I have no idea
I say want of your co-host say something
I think put put we're not even going to
acknowledge that individual cuz he did
that so that he could get
acknowledged no you can't be a
disrespectful ass human being and expect
people to want to hang out with you it's
quite simple sit it out this is one of
her co- workers on the show X cuz nobody
wants to work with it remember there we
go okay so real quick there's one more
we got to pop in okay cuz this one's
really big uh lowy Noble no we're not
going to do that oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
why you make about
that remember that
one and in case you think we're biased
and we just hate this girl are we
actually made videos in her favor you
know when she wanted to be independent
and do things her own way and she bet on
herself like yo we think it's dope that
I think she's a very talented person I
mean I wouldn't go that far but she's
talented she
has not taking accountability Talent too
that's not what I'm saying that's not
what I'm saying you putting two things
together that are not what we're talking
about she is talented it doesn't remove
the fact that she doesn't take
accountability we can acknowledge the
fact that that lady is talented what is
she's she's a I I I believe that she has
talent for being a host a talent for
being an actress the thing is that all
the bad is overshadowing all the good yo
do you guys know that she was part of
flry and right after she joined they
ended their
career she was part FL I'm not even
joking she was Y and right after she
joined the split
yeah I mean everything she part of she
just destroys really y'all think I'm
joking that's not even a joke it's it's
been a while d
yeah okay so let's see the last one
remember juicy SM okay when he did well
she was on the Reel at the time you know
the place for the real dumb views and
she had something to say about
everything that he was doing Chicago
politics is ruthless okay and I'm
telling you this is more about Kim Fox
and that situation than Jesse they're
just using Jesse as a SC come on y'all
it was no victims they can't really
prove it everything was it was a hoax
even if it was a this is really
happening all the time and even if it
was a hoax for the sake of bringing
attention to this then I'm like that's
lowkey Noble like I'm just at I'm at my
Wit's End about us centering situations
like this and wanting to make people
have to pay her faith was great now she
said him faking a whole ass hate crime
where she pretended that a bunch of
dudes with hoods you know put a noer
around his neck and threw bleach on him
right the most ridiculous hate crime
that nobody ever believed while he was
about to him somewh 11 night yeah and it
turned out to be two Nigerian dark
skinned dudes who did it instead cuz he
paid them like and she said that shit's
Noble like this BR is so goofy she's
been goofy her whole career and she
hasn't really had anybody check her in a
way that made her actually acknowledge
her own faults instead she just brushes
everything off as like I'm too smart I'm
too intelligent much like Martha Luther
King I'm being prosecuted for my smart
after being black wisted through all the
Hollywood and now she can't even get an
agent let's hear what she has to say
about her situation get an agent
supposedly I'm I'm being very
emotionally indulgent right now just
because I I live by myself so these are
the feelings I have and there's no one
here to share it with except
for so y'all are hearing
it but damn 43 and you can't get a man
to listen to your
problems tough life but it's still
everybody else let's keep
going I already
got blacklisted this
year um from certain
venues because I stood up for myself
professionally when I was
being
uh what's the
word
scammed I genuinely am
unsure what is coming next you're just
like am I going to have
agents like
and like what's the other side of this
look
like it's very
disconcerting very very
concerning ethically
morally
economically you know spiritually don't
forget spiritually because it's about
what's under the
skin we have an election I mean it's
just it's it's almost it's just it's
just a lot to process you know I've been
watching seeing this girl's videos pop
up on my timeline for like 7 years and
the only running theme that it is in
this whole thing is everyone's out to
get me that's now the only two people
who say this are people who avoid
accountability or people who are
schizophrenic now which one is sh cuz
not everybody can be out to get you all
the industry trying to Blacklist you but
why you've been kicked off multip you
given so many chances she gets on the
Reel what happens within a year she's
off the Reel why cuz it's too difficult
I remember she's on insecure they hate
the whole cast hates her even though
most of them get along why because they
scammers and they don't got no real
values and blah blah blah it's like how
is it that those black women have no
issues like working in that sphere but
you always do you move to other spaces
people constantly say you difficult
people do interviews with you you always
losing it it's like at which point is it
not just you and it not everybody else
maybe you're not meant to be part of
society maybe you're supposed to just
live off an island and be difficult by
yourself maybe I don't know but when I
see these people struggle you know with
their friendships relationships work
relationships it's just like how much
more evidence do you need to realize Mak
you just crazy you got problems I'm not
going to say crazy but the common
Dominator is definitely you crazy is you
know we throw that [__] around really
quickly wait what's the definition of
insanity I understand but sometimes
sometimes the common denominator is you
so you have to you have to sometimes you
have to look within and maybe this alone
time and makes you reflect on the ways
you've been acting or how you which you
decipher as even there it doesn't says
accountability at all
but every time there is a
reason there's all there's a reason and
then I could I could look back at some
situation where I feel I was right and I
can always find a way that I could you
know maybe I could have dealt with that
[__] better there's a way I could still
feel I'm right but you contributing to
that it takes two to tango how could you
how could you make the situation better
no cuz you know I am the way I am and I
am the way I am and I'm asserting myself
how how could you change how could you
went through this thing
a different way if we would give you the
chance to walk this path would you take
the same steps it cannot always be the
people out there to get you to get what
have you contributed into that situ cuz
you it's not like you walked in the
[__] the situation the opportunity and
you stayed and did nothing you took some
actions you spoke to some people you
spoke to some people some kind of way
you just the way you said certain things
as well I'm the first one that's going
to look at myself and be like hm yeah
maybe I should have said something like
a different way I got a very abrupt way
to address people
sometimes and it can it can come up as
I'm being short on anything like that
but you have to be like no you know what
yeah no no no I'm not tripping but I can
see how people might think I am
sometimes you while you look at in
someone or you talking to someone you
don't see your face you don't see what
your face look like you might look all
those things you can retrospect and just
look at yourself and look with it and
all of that but you know what there's
only one person that can do this there's
only one person that can do this Hey
listen it's you in her defense in her
defense she's been an actress since she
was a kid mhm
Talent we can agree or disagree I've
seen her acting she's not good but we
can agree disagree because there's
plenty of people who get opportunities
from a young age and or dog [__] so just
saying but her sing is pretty good don't
say that so she's been grown up in this
weird bubble and so that's why probably
her development's all [__] up cuz most
of these kids who grow up child stars
don't come out to be half normal people
it must with your development and and
your ability to associate with people
when you are that well known or making
that kind of money or on the screen from
a young age there's a certain probably
level of narcissism that's probably
heightened as a result of being in that
Spotlight all the time so maybe she's a
victim of her own circumstances the same
way everyone who hat on her is maybe a
victim of you know patriarchy or white
maybe she's a victim of the Hollywood
industry who
knows we'll never know we'll never know
you got any change you want to throw no
no I carry bills now here
sorry pretty good pretty good I I just
want to cover this video Circle back
yeah you know what the re you know the
real the show ended right yes when they
did a the finale she got mad because she
wasn't in it why would she be in there
she stormed out she was on for a year
listen listen listen if I invite you to
my house and you storm
out whing the door don't expect an
invitation for Christmas [__] [__] you
mean I couldn't believe it I'm like you
slapped the you slammed the door on your
way out chucking everybody out now you
want to be uh invited for a turkey
dinner
turkey dinner chicken everything about
this girl is just it's just this old
broadcasting stop that's it that's all
that's all I think about more power to
you my girl but I hope you realize it's
not everybody so are we just taking a
Victory lap absolutely no I'm not you
can take you can run I'm out of breath
already Jesus Christ uh no this is
this hey don't got to tell me twice move
[__] so I can take my lap and take your
lap [__] yeah yeah yeah we going do
my girl sometimes you're going to have
to realize that it's not just everybody
it's you I hope this time makes you
self-reflect all right uh you w know it
I I know it won't it won't it won't but
you're too far gone you're 42 you
haven't learned your lesson I doubt you
going to learn it now but hopefully
other people can learn from your
behavior good luck goodbye and we glad
that you becoming more
more what is there anything positive you
want to say I said I hope for the best
okay I wish you the best